plus tôt
[Musique]
excellent lundi 15 février à toutes et à
tous bienvenue sur rt france info au
décryptage invités analyse c'est parti
pour deux heures d'émission tout de
suite les titres un sommet aujourd'hui
et demain des président du g5 sa est la
participation d' emmanuel macron en
visioconférence que 8,19 oblige une
rencontre pour faire le bilan sur
l'engagement militaire de la france dans
cette région et préparer le passage de
témoin aux armées nationales documents
accablants selon un télégramme
diplomatique révélé par médiapart paris
aurait laissé partir les génocidaires au
rwanda en 94 à d'après l'onu environ 800
mille personnes surtout dans la minorité
tutsi ont été tués en trois mois lors de
massacres déclenchés après l'attentât
contre l'avion du président habyarimana
[Musique]
face aux variants les mesures varie en
europe au royaume uni 15 millions de
vaccinés contre le coran navires us et
quarantaine obligatoire à l'hôtel pour
les résidents en provenance des pays à
risque à l'allemagne elle ferme ses
frontières à la république tchèque et au
tyrol autrichien tout en surveillant de
près la moselle française
[Musique]
mauritanie mali burkina faso niger tchad
un an après le sommet de pau les
présidents des cinq pays du g5 sahel se
réunissent aujourd'hui et demain à
n'djamena la capitale tchadienne conviés
au rendez-vous et emmanuel macron y
participent mais en visioconférence
crise sanitaire oblige en toile de fond
la présence militaire française dans la
région
sur place depuis huit ans prévoir d'où
ces huit ans de présence et une
instabilité toujours grandissante de
plus en plus critiqué l'opération
militaire française au sahel n'a
semble-t-il pas vocation à prendre fin
dans un futur proche mais des
ajustements pourraient avoir lieu
concède la ministre des armées florence
parly qui continue de militer pour une
solution politique
dire que la france est englué dans une
guerre sans fin est faux notre présence
n'est certainement pas éternel les
progrès politiques dont dépend la
résolution définitive de la crise sont
loin d'être allé au même rythme que les
avancées militaires
il n'y a pas de solution militaire sans
solution politique
nous ne voulons pas que le sahel
devienne une sorte d'académie du
terrorisme parfois remise en cause au
sein même des pays concernés
l'intervention française devrait donc se
poursuivre et ce malgré un bilan mitigé
à l'image de la dernière année écoulée
si la france peut se targuer d'avoir
neutraliser plusieurs cadres djihadistes
comme le chef d'al qaïda au maghreb
islamique en juin dernier
elle constate dans le même temps de
lourdes pertes civiles en 2020 ils sont
plus de 2000 à avoir perdu la vie dans
les zones où le conflit fait rage depuis
plusieurs semaines l'armée française se
retrouve également sous le coup d'une
suspicion de bavures une frappe aérienne
qui visait un groupe terroriste aurait
été à l'origine de victimes civiles
selon des villageois malien paris nie
toute responsabilité mais le doute
subsiste
pas de quoi arranger l'image déjà
écornée de l'opération barkan le sommet
du g 500 doit-il poser les bases d'une
montée en puissance des acteurs locaux
la france doit-elle se désengager du
sahel réajuster son contingent celle
face à face
[Musique]
et nos invités françois chauve ancien
général de brigade expert en
géostratégie et barmaids journalistes
maliens messieurs bonsoir merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
françoise souvent si des opérations
servent à la barre kahn huit ans
d'engagement donc et plus de 50 soldats
français tués la guerre menée par paris
au sahel
elle est perdue et puis quand on
découvre trois portages on a quand même
l'impression qu'on se trouve un petit
peu de sujets je crois qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une guerre qu'on peut
qualifier de contre-insurrectionnelle
face à des gens partis devront
déterminer qui sont peu nombreux et
qu'ils ont subi de très lourdes pertes
depuis des années nous sommes là pour
stabiliser la région en attendant
justement comme vous l'avez d'ailleurs
souligné que finalement le politique
reprenne la main c'est ce que nous
attendons alors non je ne crois pas que
nous soyons dans une guerre perdue nous
sommes une guerre longue parce que ce
type de guerre c'est forcément long et
il faut faire avec et acceptées quant au
nombre de tués 50 tués
je me permettrais de dire honneur à nos
soldats mais 50 tués en huit ans cela
fait peu de soldats tués chaque année
c'est toujours trop mais quand on fait
la guerre il est normal de perdre des
hommes barmaid emmanuel macron a souvent
ces derniers temps pointé un problème de
sentiments anti français au sahel et
qu'il fallait un soutien local des
populations justement quel est le
sentiment sur place vis-à-vis de l'armée
française je pense que comme les général
a dû en fait la vision africaine n'est
pas la même c'est une guerre monde c'est
une guerre a rompu les sahéliens c'est
une guerre qui doit être court je vous
rappelle que au mali pas régulièrement
la crise a commencé depuis 2012 on est
en 2020 donc ça fait 9 ans neva c'est un
monde pour cette population déjà fragile
l'opération parquet en tant que tel on
avait vu l'année passée à des
manifestations contre la présence
française contre cette opération
française tout simplement parce que
c'est un juge qu'elle est inefficace et
pour cause
elle est là les français sont là avec
des aliments avec des moyens
sophistiqués pourtant la crise ne fait
que grandir
n'est ce pas c'était un moment donné et
puis plus les années passent la présence
française est là mais la crise décembre
et le centre du mali
emma est maintenant tellement ça tend
plus vers le sud du pays
comme on a vu il ya il ya trois cadres
et un poste de police qui a été puni
récente dans le sud du pays et donc
c'est tout ça qui fatiguent cette
population qui pense que la guerre a
trop duré
et quand les génériqueurs manque
justement cette position là c'est une
guerre longue
justement je vous propose de voir
messieurs à un sondage
ancien il date de 2013 mais sondages
mais l'est également avec ce qui se
passe maintenant à regarder les français
veulent que la france intervienne en
janvier 2021 à 51%
mais il était pourtant favorable à 75 %
en 2013 comment expliquer cette lente et
progressive érosion françoise souvent si
du côté de la france là je crois qu on a
toujours le même phénomène dans tous les
conflits que nous menons plus une guerre
est longue plus le peuple
la malienne dont on vient de parler on a
assez et le peuple français aussi
simplement parce que les guerres longues
ne représente pas grand chose
aujourd'hui on a l'impression de perdre
son temps que ça coûte de l'argent
on ne sait pas toujours où on va malgré
des directions politiques très clair
donc je crois que c'est une usure
normale de tout conflit aujourd'hui
surtout dans les démocraties où surtout
quand on fait beaucoup de médiatisation
autour d'un ou deux soldats tués avec
des cérémonies ça sensibilise les gens
et puis je dirais que c'est une on
n'aime pas la mort on n'aime pas la mort
on n'aime pas la guerre donc c'est
normal qu'au bout de huit ans il ya une
lueur de du soutien populaire
mais c'est au rôle des politiques
d'expliquer les choses et puis aussi
d'avoir la détermination d'aller
jusqu'au bout du conflit
même si le peuple en a assez on vient
d'évoquer le peuple malien wilona sont
tassées le problème c'est que déjà le
peuple malien devrait commencer à être
des solutions politiques intérieures qui
éviterait que barkan s'installe et
barkan n'est là que simplement parce
qu'il n'ya pas de solution locale et
qu'il faut bien faire quelque chose
là-bas remède la france est une
puissance internationale membres du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu
l'interventionnisme français est une
tradition un pour diverses raisons
au sahel l'une des explications c'est
pas la seule évidemment mais mais
la lutte contre l'islamisme et contre le
djihadisme pour en limiter notamment à
leur venue en europe regardez cette
citation celle de thierry mariani
eurodéputés rassemblement national je
cite on ne peut pas se permettre d'avoir
une sorte d' afghanistan bis qui
deviendrait un repaire de terroristes
dans cette partie de l'afrique on serait
immédiatement impacté en termes
d'immigration parce que ça entraînerait
une déstabilisation de la région
il faudra progressivement se retirer en
espérant que les armées africaines
prendront le relais fin de citation
comment lutter contre les groupes
djihadistes sur place sont les moyens de
la france la fin le mali pour les pays
du sahel de façon générale la question
moi je pense que la question c'est
l'efficacité de cette opération barkan
qui est en cause aujourd'hui et qui fait
qu'elle est à la fois elle est à la fois
faible au niveau des centres sondages et
au sahel et en france à titre d'exemple
seulement je vous rappelle qu'en 2013
quand l'opération car l'opération servat
n'a été lancée et c'était 5000 soldats
pour le territoire malien qui était un
million deux cent quarante mille
kilomètres carrés
aujourd'hui on a le même chiffre pour
pour cinq pays du sahel et donc et
l'opération elle n'est pas efficace tout
simplement est la preuve ok bon bien sûr
qu'il ya des gars ya des actions qui
élimine n'est ce pas des membres de
groupes d'al qaïda ou de l'état
islamique au sahel
mais c'est pas efficace et c'est là
qu'il faut revoir comment est ce qu est
cadré cette opération pour qu'elle
devienne efficace et aussi en même temps
voir comment est-ce que les soldats
nationaux
que ce soit au mali ou au burkina faso
ou au niger puis se monte en puissance
et les
les défis et c'est ce que la population
ne voit pas on ne voit pas comment est
ce que c'est les allemands puissent
prendre le relais je vous je vous
rappelle que la force conjointe du g100
ksar elle n'est toujours pas
opérationnel comme cela était si les
papiers mais comme cela a été vendu aux
populations sahéliennes et pourquoi
cette force ce n'est toujours pas
opérationnel et pourquoi encore les
actions contre la fatigue elle a perdu
56 c'est dommage c'était grave pour nous
de savoir ça mais le soldat israélien
ils sont combien qui sont mois les des
centaines et des centaines et des
centaines et c'est des milliers de
milieu des bulles et des familles qui
sont victimes alors un moment donné déjà
il se pose la question est ce que cette
guerre où est ce qu'on va aller est ce
qu'on va continuer éternellement dans
cette guerre et les premières victimes
je vous rappelle que ce sont les
sahéliens
donc voilà un peu la situation
aujourd'hui qui fait que l'opération
elle n'est pas efficace il faut le
recadrer
mais les cas de coma et je pense que
c'est là c'est là la retient dre
françois françois souvent si sachant que
si la france peut être se désengage
aussi
c'est peut-être pour mettre en avant les
responsabilités des alliés et peut-être
aussi une question pécuniaire vous
parlez également d'argent tout à l'heure
où est tout à fait bon d'abord la notion
d'efficacité dans des guerres de
contre-insurrection on prend discuter
des heures pour l'instant en gros qu'un
sens jihadistes ont été éliminés
physiquement on les a contrôlés dans un
ensemble de zones bien précises
les groupes islamistes ne font pas ce
qu'ils veulent sur le terrain ce n'est
pas parce que parfois il ya
effectivement des actions réussies de
leur part que ça prouve qu'ils tiennent
le terrain et on combien d'hommes face à
nous un face à nous on a quelques
milliers de djihadistes sur
effectivement un territoire immense à
laquelle on répond avec des effectifs
barca n'est pas la seule concernée
barkan ses 5000 hommes
la minus masse et 15000 les armes et on
qu'on parle peu de l'europe
il ya également les états unis on sait
qui on sait qu'il doit y avoir un
nouveau chef de la diplomatie américaine
qui qui doit adresser un message vidéo
lors de ce sommet aujourd'hui et demain
à n'djamena anthony blinken
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre justement
de l'europe avec la force takouba ou
encore des états unis je crois qu'il
faut être réaliste
l'europe ne se sent pas concerné par ce
qui se passe au sahel
ce n'est pas nouveau la france attend
cette intervenante l
internationalisation du conflit dans la
mesure où on considère que ce que nous
faisons au mali défend aussi l'europe
par action à direct comme l'a dit la
ministre
nous ne voulons pas que ça devienne une
base d'un jeans haïssent éventuelles
ensuite les américains mais les
américains nous est déjà des américains
nous est logistiquement en renseignement
sans doute qu'ils devraient faire plus
je ne suis pas certain formés mais il
n'y a pas très longtemps sa date de
quelques jours
le pentagone a laissé sous-entendre un
retrait supplémentaire des forces
américaines présentes présente sur place
je ne connais pas l'état des forces
américaines sur place mais je pense pas
qu'elle soit très nombreuses n'ont pas
de force
il n'y a pas de forces américaines
déployées d'une manière organisée
il peut peut-être avoir des bases de
renseignement oui effectivement mais je
crois que le combat aujourd'hui se fait
quand même sur le terrain avec des
soldats et la question que vous avez
posé sur la participation européenne
elle est là et c'est un peu d'ailleurs
la question qui est posée par monsieur
le journaliste excusez moi j'ai pas
recruter le breton 1
c'est vrai qui fait la guerre sur le
terrain et la première chose qu'on
devrait obtenir sait déjà que les armées
locales se battre correctement et c'est
ce que fait la france
alors on a formé plus de 6000 bien sûr
pas toujours avec efficacité dans la
mesure où sur le terrain ces armes et où
ces unités ne sont pas très efficaces il
faut les aider à être plus efficaces et
c'est l'objectif notamment de ceux de ce
sommet il faut que les locaux prennent
en charge leur sécurité et nous
reconnaissons que c'est pas notre rôle
d'être là en permanence pour assurer
cette sécurité militaire qui doit
assurer par les armées locales et là je
suis bien d'accord
un monsieur louis saillants lieutenant
de vaisseau et officier des forces
spéciales a écrit le livre chefs de
guerre aux éditions mareuil il y raconte
les missions ultra dangereuse pour
traquer les djihadistes mais surtout
regarder cette excitation
il faut arrêter de croire que c'est par
les armes que l'on va les avoir il faut
engager le champ des idées et leur
proposer quelque chose qui à ces
gamins-là les fasse rêver
babar m comment investir le champ des
idées c'est très important
cette voie là aussi qui est une piste à
explorer qu'on a pu explorer au mali je
vous rappelle que à nouakchott en
mauritanie cette piste est explorée et
ça a permis de freiner l as roma des
mauritaniens d'al-qaïda qui s'était
basée à l'époque dans le nord du mali
est donc au mali j'ai c'est qu'il ya des
voix qui commencent à s'élever depuis
quelques années pour explorer cette
piste à travers une conférence des chefs
pour lui
j'ai pour se prononcer sur cette
question quelle est la légalité de cet
enrôlement d enfants dans ces opérations
des étudiants artistes
est-ce que c'est donc c'est
effectivement c'est une piste à explorer
et sous le toit n'est pas à négliger
parce que la guerre d'avoir lé
psychologique quand vous avez des gamins
qui sait qu on croit vraiment qu'est ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire c'est que
ça va les amener au paradis et qu'ils
auront des femmes je sais pas quoi plein
de choses bon ils vont ils voir il faut
foncer je vous rappelle quand vous voyez
encore le rang de ceux qui constituent
les rangs de ce groupe djihadiste la
plupart c'est un jeune c'est des enfants
et donc c'est des gens aussi qui sont en
baisse vers d'autres voire peut-être
pour qu'ils réfléchissent à deux fois
avant de s'engager franchement si le mot
de la fin
changer les mâles et les mentalités
c'est un travail de longue haleine oui
tout à fait nous sommes dans la guerre
des esprits la garde et de logique 1
nous sommes face à une idéologie
mortifère le djihadisme et effectivement
il faut donner de l'espoir aux jeunes
est d'ailleurs des mots qu'on n'a pas
utilisée depuis tout à l'heure on fait
la guerre contre ces terroristes on la
fait bien je pense on est efficace ça
c'est sûr
1 mais on ne gagnera pas cette guerre si
il n'y a pas un développement
s'il n'y a pas des gouvernants qui
gouverne
s'il n'y a pas de corruption si l'argent
qu'on déverse est utile à tout le monde
et que je crois que quand on n'a plus
grand chose à perdre
on rejoint volontiers les djihadistes
puisque effectivement comme l'a dit
monsieur on a semble-t-il un avenir le
problème c'est qu'avec nous cet avenir
risque de se terminer très rapidement
car ces gens là ils seront tués
même s'ils sont jeunes et je crois que
si on veut l'éviter il faut des actions
dans le développement des actions dans
la gouvernance et malheureusement au
mali aujourd'hui il y a quand même un
problème de gouvernance et de
développement
eh bien on verra lors de ces deux jours
s'il y aura des
des annonces de gouvernance et d'actions
le rappel sommet du g 500 en ce moment
même à n'djamena la capitale du tchad
merci franz och où van sy et bara m
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes respectivement
général de brigade expert en
géostratégie et journalistes maliens le
rôle de la france en afrique toujours
mais cette fois au rwanda paris aurait
choisi en juillet 94 de ne pas
interpeller les dirigeants rwandais
responsables du génocide
selon un télégramme diplomatique de
l'époque qui est un document qui
constituerait le site à la pièce if
rythme en compte sur l'implication
française
le point en images
[Musique]
oh
non
et en direct sur arte france ce soir
alain gauthier cofondateur du collectif
des parties civiles pour le rwanda
bonsoir alain gautier merci de répondre
à nos questions s'il s'avère que paris a
bien laissé filer les génocidaires qui
était dans une zone contrôlée par les
mails l'armée française comment
expliquer que la france ait agi de la
sorte
je crois que il n'y a pas de véritable
explication le gouvernement en fait de
1994 a toujours été du côté des forces
armées rwandaises d' toujours du côté
des partisans du président habyalimana
est le seul à se manifester
déjà bien avant le génocide mais pendant
le génocide par des livraisons d'armes
et au moment de la débâcle des
génocidaires en refusant en particulier
de les désarmer
lorsqu'ils se sont réfugiés au zaïre et
qu'il faut continuer la lutte en se
réorganisant dans les camps pour promet
de revenir au rwanda
le chercheur françois granet a qualifié
ce document comme je cite la pièce
écrite manquantes
une pièce essentielle du puzzle est ce
que ça peut faire évoluer l'enquète
judiciaire en cours je ne sais pas tu
vas pas à vanter les choses est très
bien que françois g r effectivement ait
pu découvrir ce document mais elles
dorment depuis très longtemps
nous ne mettons de dénoncer ce qu'a pu
être le rôle du gouvernement en paix de
1994 dans le génocide des tutsi du
rwanda
nous ce qui nous guette le reste nous
une fille haute sphère people ali partir
le président c'était françois mitterrand
et le premier ministre était edouard
balladur oui c'était en effet un
gouvernement de coalition
mais on met les tremper dans ceux de
tenter des fusions là et comme dit on
encore au pouvoir en france je pense la
liberté drina alain juppé et
tout toutes les découvertes qu'on pourra
faire dans les archives et bien seront
toujours les bienvenus pour venir
conforter des idées que nous avons déjà
des connaissances que nous avons déjà
sur le rôle du gouvernement français de
1994 et que risquent les responsables
français qui était en poste à l'époque
ont malheureusement j'ai bien peur
qu'ils ne risquent pas grand chose à
moins que certaines personnes
courageuses ne décide de déposer des
plaintes en nom collectif des
particuliers si vous voulez nous
poursuivons plutôt en justice ceux qui
ont bénéficié de ce nom d armement des
génocidaires puisque en refusant de
désarmer ceux qui avaient commis le
génocide des tutsi eh bien on a vu
affluer ici en france un nombre
important de génocidaires que nous
tentons de traîner devant la justice
mais la justice française est
extrêmement lente et les génocideurs que
nous voulons faire juger si on utilise
une des abruzzes de toutes les
procédures qui leur sera permis de faire
et quelles sont vos espérances alors on
espère que alors bien sûr il ya c'est
peu cette découverte l'un d'eux françois
graner il y aura d'ici quelques semaines
le rapport de monsieur duclair suite à
la commission que monsieur mc ren a
constitué une voie depuis deux ans je ne
sais pas trop sur quoi on va aboutir on
va attendre c'est ce rapport de la
commission
et bien grâce qui font ce qu'on pourra
tenter contre les responsables
politiques de 1994 et sur le rôle de
paris avant pendant et après le
génocide des tutsi il existe encore des
zones d'ombré non on ne croit pas
véritablement ceux qui connaissent bien
le sujet tel que depuis très longtemps
la france le gouvernement en fait le
soutient le régime qui a été un régime
génocidaire
le président mitterrand a soutenu son
ami le président habyalimana avant que
ce dernier ne soit abattu dans son avion
et puis ce gouvernement a continué
pendant génocide à soutenir soutenir ce
gouvernement le gouvernement intérimaire
gouvernements bailleurs qui a été
constituée il faut le rappeler dans les
locaux de l'ambassade de france
et puis continue encore aujourd'hui à
soutenir des gens qui ont participé au
génocide en particulier dans le secteur
du double génocide que de nombreux
politiques l ont fait continue encore
aujourd'hui à profiter est ce que vous
attendez quelque chose de la communauté
internationale de l'onu notamment par
exemple
personnellement je n'attends pas grand
chose je le vois pas ce que leurs nuls
viendrait apporter de plus je crois que
c'est une affaire qu'il faut essayer de
régler entre les deux états entre les
deux gouvernements non franchement l'onu
la part d'afer montré qu'elle était à la
hauteur de l'événement duchesneau cité
tout prix et où je crois qu'il ne faut
pas il ne faut pas arriver par rapport à
la gouvernance internationale
merci alain gautier d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le cofondateur du collectif des parties
civiles pour le rwanda rester sur rt
france dans un instant gros plan sur
l'europe qui ne baisse pas la garde face
au coc u19 outre-manche on se félicite
d'avoir vacciné à plus de 15 millions de
britanniques mais le royaume uni durcit
son arsenal pour éviter l'importation
de variation du cours aux navires us
l'allemagne à elle fermée hier ses
frontières avec la république tchèque et
le tyrol autrichien et surveille de très
près la moselle
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée de la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'altitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
de salariés écrit au dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même il
n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
duquel il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
ce gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas dans l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham changer
l'équilibré stratégique pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complète drogue était
le seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qui unira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords
d'abandon
[Musique]
très bonne soirée à toutes et à tous
l'info continue sur arte france il est
20h30 heure française direction la
belgique où les coiffeurs ont rouvert
mais les restrictions sanitaires perdure
la plupart des commerçants devront
patienter jusqu'au 1er mars pour ouvrir
également le monde de la musique lui
aussi se languit pour alerter sur la
détresse du monde culturel une
initiative celle d'un guitariste réunir
une quinzaine de personnes dans l'église
de crupet dans la province de namur tout
en prenant soin de respecter les gestes
barrière une opération qui risque de se
solder par une forte amende eux le
musicien quentin du jardin nous livre
son témoignage
quentin dujardin bonsoir merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
ce soir dans quel état d'esprit ce que
vous êtes au lendemain de l'intervention
des forces de l'ordre dans cette église
alors que vous étiez en plein concert
triste en raison d'une amende que vous
risquiez d'écoper ou bien heureux parce
que vous avez fait parler de vous et
vous avait alerté sur la détresse que
rencontrent les musiciens et les
artistes contraint de ne pas travailler
en raison d'actes les sanitaires alors à
cette heure-ci il est à peu près huit
heures et demie du soir je ne connais
toujours pas moins la décision du
procureur du roi quant à savoir s'il va
poursuivre ou pas la verbalisation je
suis sujet une verbalisation de 4000
euros identique pour la personne qui a
ouvert l'église où 4000 euros et 250
euros par personne présente dans ce dans
cette église donc un montant total d'un
peu moins de 2000 euros et j'attends à
ce jour une réponse de la part du
parquet général
donc l'équivalent chez nous du préfet en
france chez notre procureur ne prévient
pas de la verbalisation
c'est sûr que le problème est assez
complexe au niveau juridique et l'acte
qui pourrait bien être qualifiés d'actes
politiques plutôt qu'une interdiction
finalement bravé pour pouvoir un acte de
culture on va dire puisqu'il s'agissait
du d'émerger de faire émerger la
question culturelle au plus haut niveau
ce crime ce qu'on appelle le comité de
concertation et ce comité de
concertation finalement chez nous depuis
à peu près cinq mois d'ici
ce planches se penchent absolument plus
sur la question culturelle a disparu
dans quel état d'esprit est ce que vous
êtes alors à ce que vous êtes triste
parce que du coup il ya tout le côté
amende ou est-ce que vous êtes heureux
parce que vous faîtes entendre votre
voix est celle des musiciens qui ne
peuvent exercer
je n'ai aucune crainte quant aux ânes
ont donc je n'ai aucune tristesse parce
qu'il ya des centaines de gens qui sont
prêts à payer et participer à cette
amende éventuelle si elle a bien lieu et
je suis très heureux d'avoir redonné une
fille par quelques spectateurs d'avoir
permis à la culture de d'exister
symboliquement et moi personnellement à
titre personnel d'avoir pu jouer cinq
minutes avant d'être arrêté par la
police
la tenue des cultes est autorisée en
belgique
vous pensiez que la police est là
intervenir vous vous y attendiez vous ne
vous y attendiez pas alors l'action a
été présentée depuis une semaine aux
médias donc évidemment nous avons
communiqué en prévention à l'ensemble de
la population et donc au parquet fédéral
qui m'a contacté deux jours avant la
prestation qu'on me dire monsieur du
jardin voici les amendes que vous
encourez parce que vous souhaitez
persister dans votre acte évidemment
pour moi la question était évidente que
oui je crois qu'il est nécessaire
maintenant de deux braves et on va dire
quelque part ces absurdités qui sont
créés par ces arrêtés ministériels ou
circulaire on va dire ça comme ça chez
qui mène en fait à des situations
absurdes en ce sens que un traître est
bien autorisé en belgique a officié
devant quinze personnes 15 fidèles mais
si ce prêt était remplacé par un artiste
est bien là la police intervient et nous
sommes verbaliser presque un an de crise
sanitaire
dans quel état d'esprit sont
les artistes en belgique on vient de
paraître de vodka vous parler d'
absurdité
en france il ya eu des victoires de la
musique des artistes comme benjamin
biolay ou jean louis aubert ont appelé
la ministre française de la culture
roselyne bachelot à rouvrir les salles
c'est pareil outre quiévrain
oui bien sûr celle où il ya un silence
qui devient très très pesant je dirais
les que la précarité s'est mécanisée
mécanisée par cet état qui est
réellement un état finalement de non
droit par rapport au fait que la
constitution est totalement bafoués et
en réalité pour l'instant on est sur ce
fil tendu de ne plus très bien savoir ce
qui va se passer avec la réouverture ou
pas en tout cas moi mon geste se
limitait profondément a dénoncé cette
question d' absurdité qui apparaît
effectivement de plus en plus prégnante
aussi aux yeux des tribunaux puisqu'il
ya de plus en plus de surcharge de
procès verbaux qui sont dressés et qui
en fait font état de ces absurdités mais
qui sont devenus ingérables au niveau
des tribunaux donc finalement en tant
qu'artiste je pense que c'était de mon
devoir de ramener cette question
culturelle avec un geste fort avec une
action symbolique qui retenait peut-être
du sens au combat des artistes parce que
vous savez où d'un moment la question de
d'être entendue à travers des cartes
blanches des écrits dans les journaux
etc ne suffit plus il faut avoir je
pense une action symbolique qui va
frapper un coup on va dire dans un sens
symbolique la table des négociations
gouvernementales pour se faire entendre
et donc c'est bel et bien ici en
belgique
la question de la liberté de culture que
j'ai bel et bien soulever puisque c'est
ce qui n'existe pas inscrit dans notre
constitution nous avons la liberté de
culte comme vous en france la liberté
d'expression la liberté de réunion
mais la liberté de presse évidemment
mais la liberté de culture est quelque
chose que je revendique maintenant
absolument dans l'inscription dans la
constitution pour ans ne plus en arriver
à ces 1 considération envers les les
artistes en général et donc évidemment
si les ministres de la culture en france
et en belgique souhaite se cordonner
dans une pensée qui pourrait peut-être
faire évoluer la question je pense que
nous serons sur un chemin positif pour
les artistes vous avez
évoquer canton du jardin la précarité
qui augmente
du côté des artistes est ce que vous
vous avez encore des rentrées d'argent
et comment vivent la plupart de vos
confrères en ces temps difficiles de
crise alors moi j'ai ce qu'on appelle je
vis avec l'équivalent de l'intermittence
du spectacle chez vous je suis comme un
intermittent du spectacle j'ai ce statut
artistique qui me permet de vivre avec
1200 euros mais j'ai quatre personnes à
charge
avec évidemment comme beaucoup de
personnes une maison d assurance voilà
une voiture à payer vous rendez bien
compte que le seuil de pauvreté est
largement dépassé et je dirais que le
seuil de l'indécence de ce gouvernement
de ne pas apporter une bouffée d'oxygène
une bouffée d'air ou en tout cas
d'autoriser au minimum un artiste à
pénétrer un lieu culte pour pouvoir
simplement gagner un tout petit peu
dignité et peut-être un tout petit peu
sa vie parce que j'accepte en fait le
chiffre de 15 qui est extrêmement réduit
mais je l'avais évidemment sur cette
journée répercuter sur cinq concerts
d'affilée espacées de 20 minutes chacun
ce qui me faisait un public de 75
personnes et donc de pouvoir gagner ma
vie décemment si vous faites payer 15 ou
20 euros la place au bout de la journée
vous pouvez dire que vous avez gagné un
salaire correct au vu en tout cas la
destruction de ce secteur de la culture
donc l'action était réellement de
pouvoir aussi dire aux artistes
voilà une brèche engouffré vous le culte
est en solidarité avec les artistes
je pense qu'il est également en france
il ya plusieurs personnes qui se sont
prononcées aussi de ce côté là et
j'espère que que cet acte fort va
permettre sur nos pays en tout cas
qu'ils pensent de la même façon dans
cette liberté d'expression qui est
tellement cher à la france
chez nous elle est je pense assez bien
amoindrie et la question du silence à
l'heure actuelle de la part du parquet
fédéral m'impressionne comment tu as
peut-être une volonté d'éteindre la
flamme ou en tout cas de la limite et en
douceur merci content du jardin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions nous avoir livré
votre témoignage de ce qui s'est donc
passé
hier en belgique je rappelle que vous
êtes artiste guitariste pays voisins de
la belgique l'allemagne
l'allemagne avec berlin qui est durcie
ces restrictions sanitaires pour limiter
la circulation des variants dussart sauf
deux le pays a fermé hier ses frontières
avec la république tchèque et le tyrol
autrichien et surveille de très près la
moselle française bruxelles et viennent
se montre critique
emily cook h au poste frontière de
kieffer spelden dans le sud est du pays
les entrées sont patiemment filtrés par
la police pour pouvoir passer la douane
il faut désormais remplir plusieurs
critères être allemand ou résider en
allemagne mais surtout présenter un test
de dépistage du coc vite 19 récent est
négatif pour cette conductrice
autrichienne c'est la mauvaise surprise
kerouay je viens du tyrol je voulais
seulement traverser l'allemagne pour
aller à vienne hier soir j'ai lu que
l'on pouvait transité par l'allemagne
avec un test négatif est pauvre rêve
c'est une catastrophe
j'ai un chien qui a 15 ans dans la
voiture je vais devoir traverser
l'autriche pendant des heures je ne
connais pas le chemin et je n'ai pas de
gps
c'est super les frontaliers mais aussi
des professions considérées comme
stratégiques bénéficie cependant d'une
exception à condition toujours de
présenter un test pcr négatif de
nombreux automobilistes ont dû faire
demi tour
les personnes auxquelles l'entrée refusé
sont rassemblés avec leurs voitures
une voiture de police arrive devant le
convoi et ensemble ils prennent la route
pour retourner en autriche a offert au
petit kingston le même filtrage est
effectuée à la frontière avec la
république tchèque
un millier de policiers sont mobilisés
pour assurer ces contrôles une décision
qui n'est pas du goût de l'union
européenne bruxelles redoutent le chacun
pour soi et une remise en cause de la
libre circulation dans l'espace schengen
mais pour l'allemagne qui pointe la
lenteur de la campagne de vaccination
coordonné par bruxelles priorité est
donnée à la sécurité et à la protection
de la population
je pense que nous avons besoin du
soutien de bruxelles maintenant en
particulier en ce qui concerne la
vaccination
il ya beaucoup de travail à faire
bruxelles peut apporter une contribution
importante pour tout cela ici à la
frontière c'est ce que font la police
fédérale et celle du land
afin d'obtenir le meilleur résultat
malgré des chiffres de contamination en
baisse en plus de ces restrictions aux
frontières
l'allemagne vient de décider de
maintenir au moins jusqu'au 7 mars
le confinement partielle de sa
population à nouvelles restrictions aux
frontières également au royaume uni si
londres se félicite d'avoir vacciné
quinze millions de britanniques le pays
impose une quarantaine obligatoire à
l'hôtel pour les résidents en provenance
des zones à risque le premier ministre
un boris johnson entend toutefois
organiser une sortie je cite prudente
mais irait vers 6h et visible
irréversible à quand un mot clair une
campagne de vaccination de masse qui
laisse entrevoir la lumière au bout du
tunnel avec quinze millions de
britanniques ayant reçu au moins une
dose de vaccin contre le coc vie 19 soit
22% de la population
le royaume uni est largement en tête
dans la course à la vaccination en
europe
en visite dans un centre de santé de la
banlieue de londres ce lundi
boris johnson a évoqué la fin du
confinement en angleterre le premier
ministre dévoilera son plan de
déconfinement lundi prochain
les dates du déconfinement que nous
allons fixer seront les dates auxquelles
nous espérons pouvoir faire quelque
chose au plus tôt si vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est donc la date
souhaitée à laquelle nous espérons faire
quelque chose au plus tôt si en raison
du taux d'infection
nous devons mettre quelque chose de côté
la retarder un petit peu nous
n'hésiterons pas à le faire
je pense que les gens préféreraient
largement voir un programme prudent mais
irréversible et qui se déroule
raisonnablement en fonction de notre
situation vis-à-vis de la maladie
un déconfinement par étape serait donc
privilégié avec comme maître mot la
prudence
le gouvernement espère notamment pouvoir
rouvrir les écoles le 8 mars prochain
si la situation épidémiologique
s'améliore au royaume uni la pression
reste forte sur le système de santé
le nombre de britanniques actuellement
hospitalisée est à un niveau plus élevé
que lors de la première vague en avril
2020 nous pouvons voir que le nombre de
cas diminue fortement dans l'ensemble le
nombre d'hospitalisations diminue mais
il est encore trop élevé vous savez
selon le dernier décompte il y a encore
23000 personnes atteintes du coc vide
qui sont hospitalisés bien sûr le chemin
est encore long
et vous savez d'une certaine façon le
message le plus important reste le
message demandant à chacun de rester à
la maison et de respecter les règles de
leur côté les variants brésilien et
sud-africains continuent d'inquiéter les
autorités
conséquence les restrictions aux
frontières ont été renforcés depuis ce
lundi toute personne arrivant au
royaume-uni devra se soumettre à deux
tests pcr au cours d'une période
d'isolement obligatoire de 10 jours une
quarantaine dans un hôtel surveiller est
désormais imposé à tous les résidents
britanniques et irlandais venant de pays
jugés à risque 33 destinations ont été
placés sur liste rouge par le
gouvernement nous allons appeler tous
les clients chaque jour pour vérifier
s'ils ont une quelconque préoccupation
mais en plus de cela il ya une crise de
contact avec un service sociaux
organisés
par le gouvernement pour s'enquérir de
leur santé mentale avec des
professionnels de santé
donc seulement deux ou trois appels par
jour 5000 chambres ont d'ores et déjà
été réservé par le gouvernement mais la
capacité pourra s'étendre à 58 mille
unités
si la situation l'exigé ce séjour
obligatoire à l'hôtel ne sera pas
gratuit
loin de là la quarantaine de dix jours
aura un coût total de mille sept cent
cinquante livres soit près de 2000 euros
par personne et en direct à de
grande-bretagne à baratte bank kenya
expert en maladies infectieuses à
l'université d'exeter c'est notre
rubrique
vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir parat kahniens merci de répondre
à nos questions sur rt france calme et
15 millions de personnes vulnérables
vacciner donc outre outre manche ce qui
démontre une bonne organisation
logistique était doses qui sont
présentes contrairement à certains pays
européens comment est ce que vous
expliquez cela grâce à l'armée notamment
résultat d'efforts coordonnés afin de
d'assurer l'approvisionnement la prison
est très important car sandoz on ne peut
pas avoir de programme efficace donc
avec les dos nous avons également un
système médical bien en place avec des
médecins généralistes et à un réseau qui
les soutient plus les grands hôpitaux
c'est grâce à cela que nous avons obtenu
ce résultat et cela contraste bien avec
les erreurs des programmes de tests et
de traçage qui était organisée au niveau
privé donc la leçon à retenir c'est que
les services locaux du nhs fonctionne
mieux l'organisation mondiale de la
santé donne son homologation d'urgence
aux vaccins du laboratoire britannique
au suédois astrazeneca ce soir ou en
france il ya beaucoup de polémiques
autour de ce vaccin
d'ailleurs une nouvelle campagne de
vaccination pourrait être organisée à
l'automne selon le gouvernement
britannique est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il ya
un problème d'efficacité contre contre
les variants astrazeneca hawkswood
vaccine britain's pour astrazeneca ses
protégés et si j'étais en france je me
dirai mieux vaut lui transmet que ne pas
l'utiliser
je ne dis pas que la france a tort je
dis que mon sens est sûre et plus
efficace utilisé un vaccin qui empêche
de développer des formes graves de la
maladie et que sauver des vies le point
important du vaccin
s'agissant de changements qu'on pourrait
apporter aux vaccins ce n'est pas un
problème majeur car les virus on le fait
pour lutter peuvent changer et au fur et
à mesure de ces mutations de ces
changements nous pouvons reformuler les
vaccins existants afin qu'il protège
contre ces nouvelles mutations donc ce
n'est pas un problème majeur et c'est
tout à fait faisable
comment est-ce que vous accueillez les
nouvelles dispositions aux frontières
annoncées par le gouvernement
britannique deux tests pcr quarantaine à
à l'hôtel des filatures cela va être
très compliqué qui d'abord il faut être
scientifique dans notre accroche refont
nous il élude les personnes à la
frontière du royaume
mais n'importe quel être inscrit sur
cette liste donc il faut être très
prudent
il faut également être très prudent sur
un autre point dans ces hôtels
il faudra avoir des ces contrôles des
barrières sanitaires efficaces car sinon
il d hôtel rempli de personnes à 40h
peuvent se transformer en foyer de
contagion d'une chambre à l'autre du
côté de la grande-bretagne en attend le
22 février lundi prochain avec une
nouvelle feuille de route du
gouvernement
dans quel état d'esprit sont les
britanniques la population britannique
je n'oublie pas nos affaires en fonction
des dates les devants je fier aux
chiffres h&m chiffre montre que
l'électorat fait que le taux
d'hospitalisation de baisse et que la
population supporte non c'est une bonne
chose
notre comportement ne devait pas être
déterminée par les dates clés par les
données
dernière question le premier ministre
boris johnson a parlé d'une sortie
progressive mais irréversible
est-ce qu'on peut être agir de la sorte
quand on sait qu'il ya des variants le
mot variance et varié donc être
irréversibles comme ça quand on voit le
début de la crise sanitaire depuis un an
ça change tout le temps on peut vraiment
être irréversibles notre goût du jeu
passe il ne sonnait pas sympa visage du
mot irréversible et contre des maladies
contagieuses on doit prendre des
décisions en fonction de la hausse et de
la baisse les contagions fait être prêt
à revenir sur ses décisions en l'espace
de quelques mois il a vu effectivement
au royaume-uni a lancé un premier conte
financer un deuxième puis un troisième
rien est irréversible merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions à battants kenya
je rappelle que vous êtes expert en
maladies infectieuses à l'université
d'exeter en grande bretagne 15 millions
de vaccinés donc outre-manche et début
de la campagne de vaccination au liban
le processus a débuté hier à beyrouth 28
mille 500 doses du vaccin de pfizer du
high tech sont arrivés sur place samedi
soir
un soulagement pour un pays du cèdre
confronté depuis des mois à de multiples
crises sanitaires sociales économiques
pierre pissavy yvernault
il est officiellement le premier
libanais à se faire vacciner contre le
coc vie 19 lui elle c'est le docteur
mahmoud hassoun chef du service de soins
intensifs de l'hôpital rafic hariri au
sud de beyrouth
et dès ce dimanche le liban lance sa
campagne de vaccination sont concernés
l'ensemble du personnel médical et les
citoyens de plus de 75 ans pour le
précédent premier ministre est la
vaccination représente une première
étape vers le retour à la vie normale
nous lançons la campagne nationale de
vaccination contre le coc vide 19 avec
des vaccins de haute qualité efficace et
digne de confiance
par la suite nous commencerons à lever
petit à petit les restrictions que cette
pandémie nous a imposé et donc la vie
reprendra dans des secteurs variés
quand nous aurons atteint l'immunité
collective souhaité une chaude
une bonne nouvelle également pour les
hôpitaux du pays
nombre d'entre eux sont saturés le taux
d'occupation soins intensifs est souvent
très élevé
une campagne est vécue comme un
véritable soulagement par le personnel
soignant libanais aujourd'hui nous
venons nous faire vacciner
nous sommes vraiment heureux parce que
honnêtement c'est fatigant au travail on
a tout le temps peur chaque patient dont
vous vous approchez pour faire un bilan
de santé
vous ne savez pas s'il est positif au
qu'ovide ou non nous devons toujours
prendre toutes les précautions
donc nous sommes très heureux
blake worsley depuis le début de
l'épidémie
334 milles libanais ont été touchés par
le coni 19 avec près de 4000 morts
avec cette campagne de vaccination le
pays espère désengorger les hôpitaux et
continuer la levée progressive des
restrictions imposées le 8 février
dernier
restez sur rtl france dans quelques
instants on parle de la situation
sanitaire en france le département de la
moselle est surveillé comme le lait sur
le feu en raison des variants tout comme
la région de dunkerque
la france toujours en sursis et vite
pour l'instant un troisième confinement
a tout de suite tort
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le son et les larmes on
les a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état
je pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom aide en ligne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et
big for donc les cafards s'organiser
pour annuler quelqu'un sur internet sur
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux hanul à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que des gants dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose d'inouï
tg les gens qui s'étaient des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la minus maël compte au moins quatorze
mille militaires et policiers déployés
ou mais non s'est-elle face c'est une
mission de paix de la chose unis mais la
vérité c'est qu'elle est connue dans un
angle difficile comptant un ennemi un
ennemi invisible et les premiers pas en
turquie le premier qu'elle a des
qualités qui est là pour faire du mal
mais grâce à notre détermination nous
sommes très différents
on a le sentiment que c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sel tout les
terroristes quel est votre constat la
menace terroriste est une menace pour le
bas et que sa réponse doit être souvent
de la solidarité au bas
les accords d'abraham change l'équilibré
stratégique pour le moyen-orient après
50 ans d'immobilisme dans cette région
complète tron était le seul à pouvoir
créer les conditions d'une paix durable
grâce à ses relations différentes avec
tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment jma va traiter un sujet s'il
relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran qui unira les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accros de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'il ya un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que que la france a été
plus mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes
et étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dans la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir mais comment
est-ce qu'on va retrouver un équilibre
en faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
il est 21h heure française excellente
soirée à toutes et à tous
si vous nous rejoignez à place à une
deuxième heure d'information tout de
suite les titres de ce lundi 15 février
la france a plus que jamais en sursis
pour éviter un recond filmant en cause
les variants du courant navires us qui
continue d'inquiéter radin qu'hier qui
en moselle où trente mille doses de
vaccins supplémentaires sont attendus
alain fischer le monsieur vaccin du
gouvernement soit immunisée avant l'été
les personnes dites à risques
[Musique]
rencontrent ce matin assez peu à saint
pétersbourg entre le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov et son
homologue finlandais au coeur des
discussions
les relations entre moscou et bruxelles
avec en filigrane les tensions ravivées
par la sphère navalni le kremlin dénonce
une ingérence de la part des capitales
occidentales
[Musique]
10e anniversaire aujourd'hui de la
révolution libyenne un soulèvement
populaire le 15 février 2011 dans le
sillage du printemps arabe qui renverse
le pouvoir de mouammar kadhafi la libye
plus que jamais divisée tente de panser
ses plaies et se reconstruire au coeur
d'un grand jeu géopolitique mais dans de
nombreuses nations
[Musique]
mesure déconnecté c'est un cycle maire
divers gauche de dunkerque a qualifié ce
matin le choix préfectoral de garder les
écoles ouvertes malgré l'accélération de
la circulation du variant anglais ducobu
de 19
une décision qui intervient alors que
beaucoup dénoncent un millefeuille
administratif pesant quant aux
orientations sanitaire nadège abderrazak
je suis sincèrement convaincu que nous
avons fait les bons choix au bon moment
mon seul souci c'est de prendre les
bonnes décisions au bon moment
les bons choix les bonnes décisions au
bon moment
l'exécutif parle d'une seule voix pour
se féliciter de la bonne gestion de la
crise sanitaire et pourtant les couacs
ne manquent pas on se rappelle de la
polémique autour des masques des tests
est aujourd'hui autour de la vaccination
tout et son contraire a été dit ou
presque
les masques étaient au départ inutile
voire dangereux pour se retrouver
finalement obligatoire pareil pour les
tests très peu nombreux au début de la
pandémie ils sont aujourd'hui proposées
un peu partout dans les hôpitaux
cliniques pharmacie et entreprises
le top départ de la campagne de
vaccination contre le commis de 19 a été
lancée en décembre
le démarrage a été tellement poussif qui
l'a poussé emmanuel macron à mettre les
points sur les i je ne laisserai
personne jouer avec la sûreté et les
bonnes conditions encadrés par nos
scientifiques et nos médecins dans
lesquelles la vaccination doit se faire
et je ne laisserai pas davantage pour de
mauvaises raisons
une lenteur injustifiée s'installer je
ne confonds pas vitesse et précipitation
avait alors répondu le ministre de la
santé
olivier veyrat et pour sa défense il
peut être délicat d'allier vitesse et
efficacité
d'autant plus quand il faut passer par
des centaines d' interlocuteur ou des
dizaines de structures avant que
l'information remonte au plus haut
niveau
en témoigne cette infographie où l'on
voit plusieurs acteurs de la gestion de
l'épidémie et les différents circuits
fut deux des six
en outre le côté politique et
décisionnel avec la présence du
président de la république le conseil de
défense le premier ministre et son
gouvernement le ministre de la santé le
ministre de l'intérieur les préfets les
maires on retrouve aussi des structures
spécialisées dans la santé la haute
autorité de santé
le comité consultatif national d'éthique
le comité analyse recherche expertise le
haut conseil de la santé publique et
caetera et caetera et je ne les ai pas
tout citer
vous l'aurez compris cela fait beaucoup
de monde à consulter pour prendre les
bonnes décisions au bon moment
les agences régionales de santé ont été
les premières à laisser apparaître leurs
failles lors de la crise sanitaire créé
il y a dix ans pour piloter l'offre de
soins et répondre aux besoins des
populations locales
elles sont en croire certains totalement
déconnectée des territoires dont elles
ont la charge
face à la crise l'organisation du
ministère de la santé et des agences
régionales de santé a explosé en plein
vol
les ars sont à l'évidence non seulement
inadaptée à l'urgence sanitaire mais en
plus elles ont un vrai pouvoir de
nuisance
ce manque de proximité et de diffusion
de l'information a des conséquences très
négatives sur les moyens que les élus
mais aussi les préfets pourraient mettre
en oeuvre pour résoudre la crise on est
complètement abandonné
j'ai fait une demande de masques à la rs
du grand est ce début mars pour la
résidence pour personnes âgées de la
commune
j'ai envoyé des emails et même un sms ou
directeur général je n'ai jamais reçu de
réponse des attaques injustifiées selon
certains responsables d' agences
régionales de santé depuis fin février
2020 nous sommes mobilisés 7 jours sur 7
les personnels des agences ont été
blessés par la mauvaise foi de certains
élus locaux
elle est réel problème de fonctionnement
des agences s'expliquerait par plusieurs
facteurs une baisse des moyens humains
les agences régionales de santé ont
perdu 1500 postes en dix ans ainsi qu'un
manque d'autonomie puisque les airs
est-ce reste tenu au strict respect des
consignes nationales les instructions
peuvent changer d'une heure à l'autre ce
qui n'est pas sans poser quelques
problèmes pour la logistique
ces lourdeurs administratives aiguë
révèle un symptôme bien français dont on
se serait bien passé en période de crise
sanitaire ans chez pays dont on suppose
que le virus est parti il existe un
dicton pour cela le grand nombre des
bateaux ne gêne pas la rivière à méditer
sur le terrain les hôpitaux passe en
organisation de crise d'ici à jeudi pour
prévenir une aggravation de la situation
sanitaire
les personnels soignants toujours en
première ligne face à une crise dont on
ne voit pas le bout et eux mêmes
confrontés à la contagiosité des
variants c'est le décryptage
[Musique]
nos invités grégory chakir infirmiers au
chu de toulouse et porte parole du
collectif interlock et thomas bourhis
infirmiers au chu de brest secrétaire
général de la cgt à l'hôpital brestois
bonsoir messieurs merci de répondre à
nos questions et d'essayer de décrypter
la situation française grégory chakir
les hôpitaux en organisation de crise
d'ici à jeudi c'est préventif selon vous
une troisième vague est inéluctable
c'est le calme avant la tempête
oui bonsoir il c'est simple or de
d'anticipation remet tout dans l'urgence
ce qu'il faudrait c'est que y ait un
véritable plan pour les autres tours un
plan qui soient pérennes et arrêté
peut-être de voir la crise de la gérer a
toujours à flux tendu et voilà c'est ce
que je pense ou empêchent beaucoup il
faut boire au long terme et là en bas là
on est toujours un peu dans l'urgence et
dans la gestion de la peu pris il
faudrait vraiment donné les moyens
maintenant aux hôpitaux de pouvoir de
pouvoir assurer ses missions de service
public que ce soit en termes de moyens
humains et de moyens matériels ça fait
maintenant plus d'un an et demi qu'on le
dénonce avec les autres collectifs et
les autres syndicats
mais voilà les moyennes ne sont toujours
pas mis en place et les professionnels
quittent le navire l'hôpital public
sombre et on le regarde couler thomas
bourhis il y à la vaccination qui qui
est en jeu en ce moment le chu de brest
a vu sa vaccination être suspendues en
raison d'effets secondaires elles ont
repris aujourd'hui les vaccinations
souvient également de l'hôpital de saint
lô la semaine dernière a eu des effets
indésirables qui ont engendré des
difficultés dans leur galerie de
l'organisation du travail
est-ce qu'il ya maintenant une
appréhension de la part du personnel
soignant par rapport à la vaccination
forcément il ya une impression
appréhension alors il s'est avéré que la
stratégie de vaccination à brest qui est
un peu particulière c'est à dire de
mettre en place une équipe mobile qui
allaient dans les services les plus
exposés voilà on s'est aperçus qu on
avait complètement sous-estimé
là le degré d'effets secondaires qui
pourrait y avoir chez des collègues on
s'est retrouvés effectivement avec des
services où un tiers des effectifs
étaient été plus opérationnel évidemment
je rejoins le collègue qui a parlé avant
on est sur des effectifs qui sont à flux
tendu alors vous imaginez bien que un
tiers des effectifs qui en arrêt maladie
sur un service et ma le service ils
tombent plus donc heureusement
effectivement ça a été interrompue et on
a changé de stratégie à brest puisque
maintenant les vaccinations seront
échelonnés et ne se feront pas serviette
spa services comme ça de façon massive
et vous des effets secondaires
maintenant ça va mieux quand même et ses
effets secondaires seront son passé
alors oui on a pas on n'a pas dénoté de
cas graves en tout cas en effet
secondaire mais malgré tout ça a été
sous-estimé puisqu'on a des collègues
qui ont été en arrêt pendant deux trois
jours
donc ce n'était pas non plus anodin et
en plus comme ça a été plusieurs
collègues à la fois dans les mêmes
services ça vraiment entraîné
désorganisation des services en question
au chu de toulouse comment ça se passe
grégory chakir il ya des effets
secondaires aussi toulouse ou d'ailleurs
des infirmières un des blocs opératoires
étaient en grève aujourd'hui qu'un peu
suivi six infirmières et quatre aides
soignants de en grève selon la direction
à la dépêche du midi d'abord à réagir
sur cette information concernant la
grève c'est une information
lyman de la direction il en était on
était bien bien plus nombreux que c'en
est une veine tél donc en termes de
grévistes en termes de personnes
mobilisées sur le terrain donc il faut
nuancer toutes les informations que vous
vous avez qui émane de la direction
revenez toujours on est toujours
mobilisée actifs faire valoir nos
revendications en termes d'attractivité
de fidélisation du personnel qui sont
toujours refusée par la direction donc
le mouvement ne faiblit pas et est
toujours toujours bien présent et en ne
lâchant rien en termes de vaccination
ont nagé pas de réponse particulière
thomas bourhis vous êtes en première
ligne depuis presque un an
et les aides-soignants les soignants les
médecins les infirmiers les soignants
sont eux mêmes touchés en parle convient
de 19 des foyers de contamination se
multiplient au sein des hôpitaux avec
donc ce plan qui a déclenché dc dc jeudi
dans quel état d'esprit est ce que vous
êtes dans quel état d'esprit l hôpital
belge fois il ya une fatigue un peu
général effectivement il ya une
lassitude faut savoir effectivement que
depuis un an les soignants et puis tout
le personnel hospitalier on prend une
première ligne de cette crise sanitaire
il ya eu beaucoup d'effets et yvan de
consignes contradictoires donc il ya
aussi une perte un peu de confiance dans
les pouvoirs publics
là encore effectivement on nous avait
promis un changement dans le
fonctionnement dans le de l'hôpital
notamment dans l'ouverture de lits ou en
renfort en personnel honnêtement on n'a
rien vu à part une augmentation de
salaire on n'a pas vu de changement
structurel de l'hôpital est qu un moment
donné si on avait plus de place plus de
moyens je pense qu'on verrait de façon
groupe plus sereine la lutte contre
cette épidémie dont personne ne peut pas
ne peut ne peut rien faire
donc oui encore une fois il ya une forme
de lassitude une fatigue sentiment
d'insécurité permanent ou les collègues
donc d'échanger leur organisation
personnelle
ils prennent des risques et à ce niveau
là d'ailleurs il faut savoir que le
gouvernement ne reconnaît pas de façon
automatique
tous les agents qui sont comme elles
contaminés au co vide seulement les
formes de grave
s'il ya un manque de reconnaissance est
assez assez inacceptable
grégory chakir en parle beaucoup des
variants du corps un navire russe
anglais chez d'africains brésilien ce
que vous croyez qu'on ne voit pas le
bout le royaume uni pourrait d'ailleurs
vacciner à l'automne à cause de ça ça
vous fait peur écoutez c'est sûr aux
difficultés à voir la fin de cette crise
mais encore comme je vous l ai dit tout
à l'heure faut-il encore les moyens à
l'hôpital et au personnel voire ne pas
travailler en toute sécurité et assurer
la qualité des soins et là c'est loin
d'être le cas
nous la crise convient au sein des blocs
opératoires où ça je suis toulousain est
la preuve
comme je vous l'aï dit les soignants
quittent le navire les personnels de
blocs ce soit les aides soignants les
infirmiers les i mode
sans vent et filles l'hôpital public et
les blocs opératoires au signal
une considération les direction ne
respecte pas la législation en termes de
récupération ils font quoi il
démissionne et change de métier
ils vont dans le service du privé dans
les cliniques privées ils se
reconvertissent ils font ils quittent et
oui et quitte le navire il va le tablier
aucune reconnaissance en termes
d'attractivité surtout de fidélisation
nous en demande des primes pour faire
reconnaître nos compétences et les
directions et la direction de saab se
refuse à aller dans ce sens
certaines certaines ne sont capables de
le faire donc voilà on est démotivé on
est en colère et il y en ait dans une
impasse non pas en lassera pas parce que
derrière ce qu'on pense aussi que aux
patients qui subissent aussi toute cette
crise et ce manque de moyens mais ce que
j'ai envie de vous montrer un sondage
la part des français la confiance des
français envers les scientifiques en
2011 92% des français faisait confiance
aux chercheurs c'est un sondage ipsos et
entre janvier 2001 et octobre 2020 il ya
une baisse de 20 points soit 72% de
confiance des des français envers les
scientifiques comment est ce que vous
expliquez cette érosion est ce que c'est
dû à la crise du courant navires us et
les scientifiques qu'on voit sur divers
plateaux télé et bien donner un avis
puis un autre
écoutez oui c'est pas tellement étonnant
mais je pense que c'est pas seulement
les scientifiques ces essais aussi voilà
les aînés politique les pouvoirs publics
on a eu quand même depuis un an quand
même des procédures et des ordres et
contre-ordres vous pourrez revenir sur
l'histoire des masques ou un moment
voilà c'était c'était inutile et après
c'était indispensable
on a vu quand même dans les hôpitaux
aussi des changements de procédure en
fonction des pénuries de matériel un
moment donné je ne suis pas complètement
étonné effectivement il ya une perte de
confiance pas forcément ouvert un col et
scientifique mais envers un système
quand même qui a eu beaucoup de
difficultés à s'adapter à une crise et
bref sans précédent perte de confiance
également pour vous grégory chakir de
votre côté à toulouse pour faire de
confiance alors je sais pas en tout cas
une paire de son père le gouvernent ils
souffrent sur le terrain
ah oui je peux vous dire en perte de
confiance envers les envers le héros
moment et je me permets de vous couper
parce que le son commence à devenir
compliqué du côté de toulouse en tous
les cas merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions grégory chakir je rappelle que
vous êtes infirmier au chu de toulouse
porte parole du collectif inter bloc j
merci également à thomas bourhis d'avoir
répondu à nos questions infirmiers au
chu de brest secrétaire général de la
cgt au chru de brest
diamant je le disais donc tout à l'heure
le maire divers gauche de dunks hier
patrice vergriete dénonce des mesures je
cite déconnecter les élus locaux
demandait la fermeture des collèges des
lycées et la possibilité pour les
parents de ne pas déposer leurs enfants
à l'école les manières selon eux de
désengorger les classes et de ralentir
la progression des variants anglais du
coronavirus dans le département du nord
demande qui n'a pas été suivi par l'état
ou au niveau de l'ensemble des maires de
l'agglomération nous avions demandé la
fermeture des collèges et des lycées et
la possibilité pour les parents
d'enfants à l'école primaire de ne pas
mettre leurs enfants aujourd'hui jeu qui
aurait permis d'alléger les classes
considérablement l'état a choisi autre
chose
il n'a pas souhaité suivre les
recommandations des recommandations de
l'ensemble des maires de l'agglomération
on est partis sur des sur des mesures
qui n'ont rien à voir avec la réalité de
ce territoire
on se demande encore comment c'est
possible a pas de confinement localiser
ni de fermetures d'écoles donc à
dunkerque ni en moselle les autorités
temporise si les marins pompiers de
marseille sont dépêchés dans le
département pour aider à dépister dans
les eaux usées la commune voisine
deux messes de saint-avold mise elle sur
les tests préventifs pour enrayer la
progression de nouvelles souches du sang
skov 2 la ville met en place un des
tests grandeur nature notamment au sein
des quartiers populaires un centre de
vaccination était donc mis en place à
l'hôpital et 60 et de saint-avold et
nous de manière préventive nous mettons
en place un plan au niveau du test
qu'ovide sur l'ensemble des quartiers
nous avons réalisé deux tests sur le
centre ville et nous allons nous
déplacer dans les quartiers populaires
afin que l'ensemble de la population
puisse bénéficier de ces tests de
manière préventive pourquoi d'une part
parce que du coup ça mettra en alerte
les habitants et d'autre part ça
permettra tout de suite de savoir où on
en est au niveau de la contamination est
certainement du variant qui circulent en
moselle et on dirait que ce sera avec
nous sur arte france françois grosdidier
maire les républicains de metz s'est
invitée bonsoir françois grosdidier
merci de répondre à nos questions au lit
avant la visite d'olivier verront
vendredi dernier à metz vous appeliez un
confinement localiser vous n'avez pas
été écoutés le week-end passé dans quel
état d'esprit est ce que vous êtes
excédé comme votre homologue dunkerquois
bien sûr ainsi en colère parce que nous
connaissions bien la situation sur le
terrain nous observons le comportement
de nos administrés nous sommes en
relation constante avec le corps médical
dans les hôpitaux dans la médecine
libérale et on n'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi on n'est pas compris lorsque le
ministre de la santé venus vendredi
il semblait ouvert il a pu constater la
gravité de la situation le le dialogue
était et est intéressant avec lui mais
on s'est vite rendu compte qu'il ne
déciderait rien et qu'il remettait une
des six à une réunion du soir en
présence du président de la république
les décisions il nous paraissait
absolument indispensable d'une part
d'accélérer le mouvement de vaccination
on ne peut pas vaccinés au même rythme
d'ailleurs trop lent tous les
départements cela aussi téméraires qui
doivent arriver en moselle non pardon il
va y avoir 30 mille doses
supplémentaires qui doivent arriver en
moselle alors
nous avons d'abord été entendu il avait
annoncé l'après midi même 2000 vaccins
en plus qui était dérisoire parce qu'il
faut rapporter une population d'un
million d'habitants et de plus de 100000
habitants de plus de 75 ans donc avec
30000 aujourd'hui ça commence à être
sérieux mais cela dit nous maintenons
nos demandes ou pour 1 re confinement
locale est très court ou au minimum pour
une avancée des vacances scolaires parce
que ces vaccins
ils vont pas être injecté en une journée
ni même en une semaine au rythme pris
par les autorités de santé
ces semaines précédentes et surtout même
s'il était injecté en une journée ils
mettraient quinze jours à produire de
l'épée or pour nous il ya urgence à
freiner à inverser la tendance et à
freiner l'épidémie tout de suite c'est
pour ça que même à défaut d'un
confinement dans l'état ne veut pas
entendre parler pour ne pas avoir à
indemniser le chômage partiel on
attendait au moins une avancée d'une
semaine des vacances scolaires
parce que le variant se se répand
beaucoup plus chez les jeunes notamment
chez les 10 20 ans que la coville 19
classique chaque app positif aux corvées
19 sera considéré comme un variant avant
la preuve du contraire c'est suffisant
ou pas selon vous c'est suffisant ça
n'empêche pas cessé heureusement que
l'on fait seul compte tenu de
l'explosion des cas de variants chez
nous mais il suffit pas de le considérer
comme un invariant pour ralentir la
progression pour ralentir la progression
il faut éviter les contacts
il faut éviter les contacts sur ceux qui
ont le plus de mal à respecter les
gestes de prudence qui sont les jeunes
pourra tous été jeunes c'est très
difficile pour des les élèves de
primaire et même pour des collégiens ou
des lycéens de porter le masque et de
respecter la distanciation pendant une
journée entière on sait d'ailleurs que
c'est peu respectée quoi et on peut pas
en vouloir à ces jeunes bon mais
simplement quand il ya le feu
il faut prendre des mesures immédiates
et donc c'est pour faire
et sapeurs pompiers qui sont présents
dans votre département pour dépister
dans les eaux usées comment est-ce que
vous accueillez 7,7 cette action
positivement aussi mais là c'est pas les
les pompiers pour éteindre le feu
c'est très bien mais c'est eux les
pompiers de marseille pour examiner la
présence de deux variants ou pas et et
c'est une mesure de prévention qui est
positive et qui doit nous aider à mieux
cerner le problème
donc tout cela est utile comme les
vaccinations ça n'empêche pas qu'il
aurait fallu dès cette semaine un coup
d'arrêt un coup de frein brutal et le
coup de frein brutal jusqu'à présent le
seul qui ait fait ses preuves ça a été a
eu le confinement et à défaut d'un
confinement c'était au moins d'avancer
d'espèces et les la rentrée scolaire
alors les mesures comme ce mouvement de
vaccination qui va progressivement
s'accélérer où les mesures qui vont nous
permettre grâce aux pompiers de
marseille peut être d'identifier plus
précisément ce phénomène que pour
l'instant nous n'expliquons pas quoi
qu'il soit clair que les quatre variants
ça nous est arrivé de pillet depuis
maintenant un peu plus d'une semaine
qu'un jour on n'arrive même pas à
établir clairement la traçabilité en
amont ne comprend pas pourquoi les
jeunes sont plus exposés on sait pas
d'ailleurs pourquoi il vient cette
vaillance sud africain qui arrive en
moselle on a plus de mal à comprendre
l'avarié en plein à kerk dans
l'incertitude totale
toutes ces investigations ne sont bonnes
mais ces investigations ne produisent
pas encore l'heure des p comme les
mesures de prévention supplémentaire
avec la vaccination ne ne dispense pas
pour autant de nous protéger toi
confinement mais est ce que vous
comprenez la population qui serait
peut-être mécontente d'un confinement à
cause des répercussions économiques ça
sert et psychologique
non mais pas du tout ce qui mine
psychologiquement la population
c'est pas un confinement cours qui pour
eux ses effets de couvre-feu
interminable je dois vous rappeler que
nous avons commencé avant les autres
départements ce couvre-feu qu'on
l'avancé à 18 heures certains mêmes
parlent de l'avancé à 16 heures ça
exerce une pression sur ses salariés qui
n'ont pas le temps de faire que
que course et de récupérer les enfants
inventent rentrer chez eux ça tue plus
plus sûrement les commerçants qui ne
sont pas indemnisés en chômage technique
et qui perdent entre un quart et trois
cartes de leur chiffre d'affaires selon
les types de commerces eux-mêmes en sont
à dire mais mais confiné nous pour de
bon sur une période courte plutôt que
cette interminable couvre-feu qui
produit même des effets contre
productifs puisque en précipitant les
gens au même endroit au même moment dans
les transports en commun ou dans les
magasins et est bien en a plutôt une
accélération de la de l'épidémie si j'en
crois la récente étude du chu de
toulouse
dernière question françois grosdidier
l'allemagne voisine ferme ses frontières
à la république tchèque et au tyrol
autrichien
berlin dit surveiller de près la moselle
si on ne galère merkel valenta fermé ses
frontières avec votre département
comment est-ce que vous réagiriez
l'eurodéputé agir la droite constructif
fabienne keller y voit un non sens car
selon elle le virus ne s'arrête pas aux
frontières
votre votre réaction dans le virus ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières mais le
virus est porté par des personnes qui
franchissent la frontière
donc effectivement que c'est très
difficile de bloquer les frontières vous
rappelle qu'en moselle département d'un
million d'habitants nous avons plus de
cent mille travailleurs frontaliers avec
le clan bourg avec l'allemagne que
d'ailleurs le luxembourg avait en amont
à un moment envisagé de fermer la
frontière avant de se rendre compte que
70 % des soignants au luxembourg en fait
habiter en france et veut négocier au
luxembourg donc ça ne tient pas par
contre ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
l'allemagne art confiné est ce que le
luxembourg a fermé les écoles dort
effectivement ils peuvent nous reprocher
de ne pas exercer les mêmes mesures de
précaution que même dans une gestion
plus souple plus agile plus
décentralisée plus réactive alors qu'en
france tout comme 5
nous sommes sous le règne d'un
centralisme bureaucratique très déphasé
par rapport à la réalité de terrain
on a eu quelques semaines on a eu le
droit aux couples préfet eux mêmes
je suis maire de metz président des
maires de moselle se pouvait que me
féliciter de la marge de manoeuvre
laissée aux préfets à ce moment là mais
ça n'a duré que quelques semaines et le
naturel est revenu au galop et ce
centralisme bureaucratique a repris tous
ses droits
merci françois grosdidier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes maire les républicains de metz
en moselle à rester sur arte france dans
quelques instants direction saint
pétersbourg où les chefs des diplomaties
russe et finlandaises se sont entretenus
ce matin au coeur des discussions les
relations moscou et bruxelles avec en
creux la sphère alexeï navalni et puis
focus sur la libye 10 ans après sa
révolution et le renversement de
mouammar kadhafi un pays plus que jamais
divisée qui panse toujours ses plaies a
tout de suite
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes le désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa papa pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça va aller il
faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même on
vit tous les jours sans faire attention
que tout en dépend c'est l'unité de
mesure de toute chose une convention
admise par tous s'il arrive quelque
chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond un appartement on est énervé
donnait le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
au loin de paris mais toujours loin de
ce qu'il est guéri
moi j'en ai marre qu'on les passe un
tour de tracteur avec nous livre en
campagne il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
de retour sur rt france il est 21h30
heure française l'info continue
rencontre ce matin à saint pétersbourg
entre le chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov et son homologue
finlandais
au programme notamment des discussions
les relations entre la russie et l'union
européenne avec en toile de fond
d'affaires alexeï navalni la
correspondance à moscou signée antoine
gayraud il a beaucoup été question
d'europe entre les deux ministres et
plus particulièrement des relations
dégradées entre la russie et l'union
européenne
pour sergueï lavrov cette rupture n'est
pas récente et remonte à 2014 lorsque
l'union européenne a décidé je cite
d'accuser moscou de tout ce qui se
passait en ukraine ce qui a lancé le
cycle de sanctions qui perdure encore
aujourd'hui
résultat tout ce qui existait en termes
de relation concrète entre la russie et
ses partenaires européens s'est retrouvé
détruits l'union européenne a résolument
détruites tous les mécanismes sans
exception qui existait sur la base des
accords de partenariat et de coopération
en commençant par les sommets et les
rencontres annuelles qui se faisait
entre les commissaires européens et le
gouvernement russes y compris sur les
projets qui conte qui comprenait
différents espaces de coopération les
rencontres sectorielles et l'essentiel
des contacts que nous avions ici et
notamment les séances de partenariat et
de coopération qui avait le chaque année
avec la participation des ministres des
affaires étrangères de la russie et de
reprise le représentant pour les
affaires étrangères de l'union
européenne et on a vu tous les formats
de discussion on qui ont été détruits il
a également été question de la sphère
navalni et plus spécifiquement de
l'expulsion des trois diplomates
européens
d'après le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères ils ont contrevenu à leurs
prérogatives
ces diplomates bénéficie de l'immunité à
l'exception des cas quand il pratiquer
l'ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures
donc on a eu des exemples très claire de
tipnis d'ingérence qui sont tout à fait
incompatible avec eux une mission
diplomatique
et c'est le cas notamment quand il parle
participent à des manifestations
politiques dans le pays malgré les
différends l état actuel des relations
entre moscou et l'union européenne
sergey lavrov ne ferme pas la porte pour
autant à plusieurs reprises lors de
cette conférence de presse à la fin de
ces raisonnements de ces démonstrations
il a souligné que la russie était
disposée à tout moment à rétablir de
bonnes relations avec ses partenaires
européens encore faut-il que cette
volonté existe et indirects dans cette
édition pour évoquer cette rencontre
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
bonsoir que de blanchemaison merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
pourquoi la russie at elle choisi comme
interlocuteurs européens
la finlande d'abord parce que la
finlande et et sa voisine et qu'elle
partage avec elle 1350 km de frontière
que helsinki a une longue tradition de
dialogue avec avec moscou et donc les
deux ministres ont évidemment évoqué le
dans le détail leurs relations
bilatérales qui d'ailleurs vents vont
assez bien les commissions mixtes se
réunissent les ministres se voit les
échanges commerciaux fonctionnent les
responsables échangent leurs points de
vue et par conséquent les relations
bilatérales sont bonnes ça c'était une
première aspects mais le deuxième aspect
c'est que le choix de
d'helsinki était en fait la poursuite de
la visite de joseph bourrel à oskou sa
continuation en quelque sorte avec la
démonstration que monsieur lavrov a
voulu apporter les relations
institutionnelles entre la russie et
l'union européenne en tant que telle ne
fonctionnait plus puisque depuis sept
ans il n'y avait pas eu ce sommet
puisque les aubes sectoriels seraient
laissés plus en revanche les relations
avec les états mans continuer de
fonctionner et la substance des
relations qui est en fait porté par les
entreprises ou par les agents
économiques fonctionner normalement
et donc il a fini par dire que en effet
ou bien l'union européenne
voulez vous leur établir de bonnes
relations à asson à son échelon l'union
européenne en tant que telle ou bien il
n'y avait plus d'intérêt pour la russie
a considéré qu'elle avait des relations
avec l'union européenne en tant que
telle
ceci pour l'union européenne en tant que
telle naturellement ne concerne
absolument pas les etam ans donc il a
apporté sa démonstration qui d'ailleurs
est explicitée dans une interview très
détaillé qui va donner à un organe russe
le 12 février dernier et dont il a été
question pendant la conférence de presse
assez longuement la finlande claude
lelouch maison qui est aussi un membre
d'une coopération nordique la russie
s'adresse donc à d'autres pays à travers
elle oui alors cette coopération
nordique comporte la suède le danemark
la finlande mais aussi l'islande et tous
ces pays discutent entre eux de leurs
intérêts économiques communs
ce club n'est pas un club exclusif
puisque les états membres de ceux de ce
groupement peuvent aussi être pour
certains membres de l'otan comme c'est
le cas de la norvège pour d'autres avoir
été membre l'association européenne de
libre-échange inventé par les
britanniques en 1960 et que les
différents états en kit et au fur et à
mesure qu'ils adhéraient à l'union
européenne
et par conséquent c'est quelque chose
d'assez soupe ce conseil nordique
finalement a aussi un autre intérêt
c'est qu'il sert de noyaux au conseil de
l'arctique
si on y ajoute les grandes des grandes
puissances que sont les états unis et la
russie plus de canada eh bien on a le
conseil nordique avec un certain nombre
d'observateurs dont la france et d'autre
et d'autres pays européen et le conseil
de l'arctique
évidemment devient quelque chose de
stratégique avec totalement le
réchauffement climatique
l'ouverture de nouvelles voies le
nouvelle route du nord et il se trouve
que la russie à son tour va en exercer
la présidence à partir du mois de mai
prochain pour deux années donc tout cela
fait beaucoup de raisons pour que le
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
finlande soit un bon interlocuteur pour
monsieur sergueï lavrov et la finlande
comment est-ce qu'elle gère ces
questions de sécurité alors la finlande
eux qui avait déclaré sa neutralité à
l'époque de l'union soviétique
tiens beaucoup à ce qu'elle appelle
aujourd'hui un bon alignement militaire
par conséquent elle n'adhère pas et elle
n'a aucune volonté d'adhérer à l'otan
et je crois que la population la
population chinoise est très attaché à
cette forme de neutralité
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant qu'elle
n'est pas inquiète pour sa sécurité
il ya d'ailleurs un service militaire
obligatoire une conscription avec une
option pour ceux qui préfèrent le faire
sur une fosse sous une forme civile
garçons et filles et par ailleurs
évidemment la finlande qui n'a que six
millions d'habitants a un budget
militaire assez conséquents qui dépasse
maintenant 2% de son pnb
il a été augmenté d'à peu près 50%
l'année dernière elle possède des avions
de chasse une soixantaine d'avions de
chasse multi fonction d'origine
américaine est bien entendu elle a
développé une coopération importante
avec le temps comme d'ailleurs sa
voisine la semaine donc le sujet de la
de la sécurité
en finlande est un sujet important mais
la finlande ont finalement probablement
plus sur le dialogue avec ses voisins
que sur son armement pour assurer la
paix et la sécurité dans la région
merci que le mange maison pour toutes
ces analyses ce décryptage très précis
je rappelle que vous êtes un expert en
relations internationales et la russie
participent avec plusieurs pays membres
de l'otan à l'exercice naval ammann 2021
une première depuis dix ans des
manoeuvres militaires organisés par le
pakistan auquel participent également la
chine plus de précisions en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la libye commémore aujourd'hui le
dixième anniversaire de sa révolution le
15 février 2011 dans le sillage du
printemps arabe
un soulèvement populaire permettait de
renverser mouammar kadhafi après plus de
40 ans de règne sans partage depuis le
pays a basculé dans le chaos si tripoli
tente de se reconstruire politiquement
son économie et l dévasté les libyens
garde cependant espoir françois xavier
lambert avec media ski fis
il porte encore les stigmates de la
révolution qui a bouleversé sa vie et
son pays
il y a dix ans mort scène a assisté à la
chute de celui qui a dirigé la libye
pendant 40 ans alors que des milliers
d'opposants défier l'armée de mouammar
kadhafi dans de nombreuses villes les
civils ne sont pas épargnés
c'est notamment le cas de mort scène
pris pour cible par les forces de
l'ancien guide libyen
une mitrailleuse utilisées par les
forces de kadhafi m'a touché j'ai été
blessé avec deux autres hommes a été
blessé à la main l'autre au pied et ma
blessure était à la colonne vertébrale
soigner en allemagne mort scène est
revenu en libye en 2019
il veut toujours croire dans un avenir
meilleur alors que le pays tente de
retrouver la stabilité depuis la mort de
moammar kadhafi en octobre 2011
la libye s'est enlisé dans une guerre
civile aux multiples ramifications
groupes tribaux et djihadistes ont su
profiter des faiblesses d'un pouvoir
politique divisée entre deux autorités
d'une part le gouvernement d'union
nationale basée à tripoli est reconnu
par l'onu et d'autre part l'armée
nationale libyenne dirigé par le
maréchal rallye fav tard est basée à
tobrouk
chaque camp bénéficiant de l'appui de
pays aux intérêts divergents
ces turbulences ont durablement affaibli
l'économie d'un pays autrefois prospère
à commencer par la production pétrolière
elle a chuté de 90% en moins de dix ans
à cela s'ajoute une inflation galopante
et des pénuries d'essence d'électricité
de l'île
dit et selon le ministère de l'économie
du gouvernement d'union nationale les
prix de la majorité des produits de
première nécessité ont augmenté de plus
de 50% en 2020 c'est une récession sans
précédent
sans stabilité aucune réforme ne sera
possible
les investisseurs étrangers ne
reviendrons pas sans garanties de
sécurité
malgré ce marasme économique et leur
sécurité un motif d'espoir est apparue
pour les libyens un dialogue politique a
permis de désigner un nouvel exécutif
intérimaire
abdelhamid beiba sera chargé de conduire
le gouvernement jusqu'au prochaines
élections fixée à la fin de l'année et
en direct dans ce journal riadh sidaoui
directeur du centre arabe de recherche
et d'analysé politique et social à
genève et auteur également de l' ouvrage
du printemps arabe à des shs aux
éditions apollonia bonsoir rien de si tu
as oublié
merci de répondre à nos questions sur
arte france quel bilan est ce que vous
faites de ces dix ans après la chute de
mouammar kadhafi un pays coupé en deux
entre le gouvernement d'union nationale
a à l'ouest à tripoli et puis à l'armée
nationale libyenne du maréchal khalifa
haftar à l'est le bilan est très très
négatif sur tous les plans notamment sur
les plans politique parce que le temps
quand elle était revenue en 2011 a dit
oui à la fois le gouvernement de kadhafi
le régime de gueddafi et surtout l'état
libyen les gouvernements tombent
s'impose pas un problème les régimes
choses sans pose pas un problème mais
quand on casse un état ça pose un grand
problème je donne là la première
définition de l'état de max weber l'état
a le monopole de la violence légitime
autrement dit il n'ya qu'une ligne il
n'ya que l'état quel droit d'avoir une
seule armée nationale et seule police
nationale aujourd'hui on a plusieurs
acteurs plusieurs hôtes agonie souvent
pense qu'il y à l'est et l'ouest non
c'est encore plus il ya le faisaient nos
sud quasi indépendant même à l'ouest il
ya plusieurs milices
même pas ils sont une milice à leur
éclat milices de misrata au à zenten où
d'autres donc si la crise de l'état
libyen la destruction des [ __ ] est
bien la grande question qui va
rayés qui va construire cet état
évidemment la libye n'exporte pas depuis
plus qu'une année sans pétrole
d'habitude exporte plus qu'un million et
demi de barils par jour maintenant par
deux cent mille barils ou même mois par
joie la ligue 1 souffre souvent beaucoup
j'ai beaucoup d'amis à tripoli ou à
l'est et toujours il m'exprime lors
souffrance dans le quotidien depuis
depuis 2015 on vient de le dire donc il
ya deux autorités riadh sidaoui qui ce
parti qui se disputent plus tôt le
pouvoir même si vous avez évoqué le sud
l'ouest donc le gn a reconnu par le nul
à enel du maréchal haftar on sait qu'il
ya eu des élections
la semaine dernière du côté de genève à
la tête du conseil présidentiel libyen
c'est un mohamed menphis il a rencontré
son opposant le maréchal raf tard très
récemment à ce que c'est un bon signe
est ce qu'on peut espérer que la
situation se stabilise et espérons le
moi je souhaitais que ça passe pas un
consensus pas par des élections pour une
simple raison c'est toujours j'ai posé
la question
leaké a élu les 75 digues et les
présents à genève pour que ses 75 ans le
droit d'élire un conseil présidentiel
ça a mûri sting grande faute comme mû
par les libyens et l'onu doivent passer
par consensus un consensus pas par des
listes et des élections et aussi les
élections en libye
entendez avons plusieurs obstacles parce
qu'il ya eu des élections en juin 2014
les islamistes ont perdu les élections
les résultats étaient négatifs pour eux
donc ils n'ont pas reconnu les résultats
donc on a eu deux parlements à tripoli
l'autre à tobrouk à louer ça l'est c'est
ça le grand problème existe et elle
cette démocratie électorale en cette
culture de la démocratie en libye
j'ai des forts doutes parce que c'était
toujours une approche américaine la
démocratie sont des élections raison
fait on n'ira que ça n'a pas marché
aujourd'hui ils veulent forcer des
tribus libyennes à faire c'est les
élections et souvent des protagonistes
qui n'accepte pas les résultats
donc la libye doit passer par la tuerie
de consensus et enter théorie en
sciences politiques
le consensus pourrait être garantie par
les tribus libyennes
les tribus libyennes joie aux grognes
sociales et politiques plus important
que les partis politiques même là on
parle de la libye
de ce qui se passe à l'intérieur même du
pays mais il y a beaucoup de pays et
étrangers qui travaillent en sous marin
en libye
on parle d'un grand jeu géopolitique
mondiale qu'est ce qui s'y passe en
libye pourquoi ce pays est il si
stratégique c'est que évidemment la
france et une italie via la turquie les
etats-unis la russie les émirats arabes
unis même l'egypte qui s'intéressent à
ce pays même l'arabie saoudite
c'est la richesse de la libye le pape
est très riche en pétrole
je pense qu'ils ont les premiers
réservoir dans toute l'afrique dans tous
les conflits en vainqueur donc c'est ta
richesse attire évidemment tout le monde
attire tout le monde en pensant qu'à
voir une partie du gâteau libyen
nous savons bien que les ingérences
étrangères en lipides sont très très
fortes et multiples en empêcher solution
pacifique et politique et durable up lez
lille biais nous avons bien que la
turquie et le qatar
ed ils se tiennent les islamiser tripoli
l'egypte et les émirats arabes unis est
de se tirer l'armée nationale libyenne
dirigée par le mari charlie pas à ce
point la russie a une position
la france les états unis d'amérique sans
un acteur l invisible mais qui sont fort
présents sur le territoire libyen par le
pilier leur allié turc musculaire au
site un pilier de l'otan donc tous et le
7 octobre détrônant des acteurs et
projets dans les affaires libyennes a
compliqué la tâche de trouver ce qu'ils
soient bio art
dernière question riadh sidaoui près de
800 mille libyens ont fui vers
l'étranger mais en plus de ça on cet
alibi est un point de passage privilégié
pour les migrants vers l'europe
la chute de mouammar kadhafi est-ce
qu'elle a accentué l'immigration d'un
vieux continent rendant les frontières
poreuses
c'est la destruction de l'état ligue 1
par le temps 2011
l'absence de l'état ça veut dire plus de
police nationale homogène et ni cette
armée nationale homogène qui sécurise
les pays de l'est à l'ouest et du nord
au sud à qui crée un grand vide
un grand vide des bâches doux
l'émigration clandestine africaine et
surtout les terrorismes le libye devenue
un foyer des terroristes que ce soit 2 2
ce soir de qaïda
dash a eu son émirat a certes à titre
d'exemple à certains membres donc la
libye aujourd'hui c'est un foyer des
terroristes et de l'immigration
clandestine pourquoi parce que il n'ya
pas un état fort et il n'y a pas un
états unis en libye
merci riadh sidaoui d'avoir nous avoir
éclairé sur ses dix ans donc de la chute
de mouammar kadhafi en libye
je rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
du centre arabe de recherche et
d'analysé politique et social à genève
et auteur du livre du printemps arabe à
des shows aux éditions apollonia pays
voisins de la libye la tunisie où la
crise politique perdure au sommet de
l'état après le refus du président qui
essayent d'entériner le remaniement
ministériel
le chef du gouvernement est fier mais
chichi limoges cinq ministres
on retrouve tout de suite notre
correspondant à tunis bassam chimie
bassem la confrontation se poursuit donc
au sommet d'état effectivement la
situation politique est de plus en plus
incertaine est ici a accueilli son
assist vraiment à un bras de fer et un
échange de propos entre le président de
la république monsieur right side et
puis son premier ministre
hichem et chichi qui n'a pas hésité
aujourd'hui à limoges et cinq ministres
dont le ministre de l'industrie de la
justice de jeunesse et des sports de
l'agriculture ou encore de l'industrie 5
ministre qui était proche du président
de la république tu t'es les cinq
derniers ministres du gouvernement écrit
michy chypre à être proche du
gouvernement
une autre proche du président de la
république les analystes politiques ici
à tubize analyse cela comme un second
coup de poignard du prix du premier
ministre au président de la république
lui avait pourtant accordé à sa
confiance le premier était bien
évidemment le remaniement ministériel du
26 janvier dernier qui proposait onze
nouveaux ministres parmi lesquels le
président de la république a refusé
catégoriquement certains le juger comme
corrompus d'autres qui n'étaient pas du
tout en phase avec la politique doit
être adapté ici en tunisie le président
de la république a adressé ce soir une
lettre au premier ministre lui ai
rappelé en a bien sûr
l'aspect non constitutionnels de cette
démarche et surtout ce passage en force
avec la nomination de ses nouveaux
ministres je vous propose d'écouter de
voir un extrait de cette lettre adressée
au premier ministre il s'agit de
rappeler certains principes selon
lesquels le pouvoir en tunisie doit
exprimer la volonté du peuple
la prestation de serment ne se définit
comme une procédure formelle ou
fondamentale mais par l'engagement à
respecter le texte du serment et les
conséquences qui en découlent non
seulement dans la vie sur terre mais
aussi devant l'éternel à bassam chebbi
comment est ce que cette crise politique
peut-elle évoluer avec la démission du
premier ministre et chats mais aussi
chez effectivement toutes les solutions
sont à l'étude présente lui qui a même
reçu jeudi dernier une poignée de
députés au palais de carthage
objectif étudier les possibilités de
sortie de crise notamment aux paroles le
biais d'un référendum ou encore d'un
dialogue national la démission du
premier ce n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
le premier ministre compte bien rester
est positionné à car il fait le jeu de
certains partis politiques notamment
celui du parti islamiste ennahda au
pouvoir qui ont bien orienté beaucoup
des décisions du premier ministre depuis
qu'il a pris ses fonctions notamment la
nomination de certains ministres encore
le limogeage de ces cinq ministres qui
est proche du président tae sae donc une
démission du premier ministre mais
celui-ci je ne pense pas que cela soit
l'ordre du jour je pense pas que cela
puisse arriver prochainement
le président de la république a ouvert
le dialogue attend encore que son
premier ministre puis ce lot revenir à
la raison et surtout respecter la
constitutionnalité de ces démarches et
politiques notamment au niveau du
remaniement comme un niveau de certaines
nominations on a pu discuter avec
certains a débuté qu'elle ait rencontré
le président de la république au palais
de carthage il nous indique toutes les
possibilités étaient à l'étude
mais la première carnet est ressorti est
vraiment ce dialogue national qui doit
être fait car cette sortie de crise sera
faite bien sûr avec une alliance qui
pourrait être fait entre différents
partis politiques mais surtout en
prenant en considération et la parole du
peuple et surtout le sel de la société
civile ici en tunisie
merci ça me chéri pour toutes ces
précisions
donc en direct de tunis on reste en
afrique avec le début aujourd'hui en
république démocratique du congo d'une
campagne de vaccination non pas contre
le commis le 19 mai contre le virus
ebola
cette fièvre hémorragique souvent
mortelles est réapparu dans l'est du
pays au début du mois une précédente
épidémie avait pris fin au mois de
novembre quatre cas dont deux mortels
ont été recensés selon l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
et voilà qui ressurgit également en
guinée un nouveau mort annoncée
aujourd'hui dans le sud est du pays
portant le bilan à quatre décès parmi
les sept qui a enregistré la guinée
forestière d'où elle était déjà partie
la pire épidémie de l'histoire de ce
virus entre 2013 et 2016
emilie google cinq ans après la fin de
l'épidémie
la guinée affronte de nouveau ebola
selon le directeur de l'agencé sanitaire
les contaminations ont eu lieu lors d'un
enterrement
l'inhumation d'une infirmière infectés
qui s'est déroulé au début du mois à
bout etc et en guinée forestière
malheureusement
s'ils combinent donc l'enterrement en
jeu ah oui qui la partie du prêt vert
rire et malheureusement certaines
personnes qui ont pris part à cet
enterrement
quelques jours après on commençait à eu
de manifestation de dire les
vomissements s'est mariée de la fière
une situation épidémique qui inquiète la
population
déjà préoccupés par la pandémie de kovy
19 et qui rappellent de mauvais
souvenirs entre 2013 et 2016 le pays
avait connu la pire épidémie de
l'histoire du virus ebola le monde
paniquait ap encore sommes des africains
ne sont pauvres et signe maladie comme
ebola ou bien qu'on a vu apparaître en
afrique
donc vraiment séduit seulement va nous
sauver
ça m'a vraiment surpris compte tenu de
la situation actuelle de la gauche nous
d'hiver avec la pandémie plus en 2013
depuis le sud est de la guinée ebola
s'était propagé dans les pays
frontaliers au liberia et en sierra
leone
trois ans plus tard l'épidémie s'achever
après avoir atteint 10 pays dont
l'espagne et les états unis et bull
avait alors entraîné la mort de plus de
onze mille trois cents personnes dont au
moins 2500 dans la seule guinée malgré
le développement d'un vaccin par un
laboratoire canadien
il n'existe toujours aucun vaccin
homologué ni traitement c'est la fin de
cette émission merci à mes league ligue
1 guillaume fils david luiz et louis aux
équipes techniques de jean-christophe
chapotot merci également aux équipes de
la newsroom de lauriane d'art beaucoup
anne krystel dao
quant à nous on se retrouve d'ici
quelques inscrits pour un nouveau jt à
22h heure française a tout de suite
[Musique]
la minustah est contre -14 mille
militaires et policiers déployés au mali
n'ont fait elle face c'est une mission
de paix des nations unies
mais la vérité c'est qu'elle est venue
dans un endroit difficile quand on vend
une ennemie un ennemi invisible
un ennemi qui ne prenait pas pour dire
qu'il ne connaît la qualité qui est la
mère hlima mais grâce à notre
détermination nous sommes en train d'y
faire face
on a le sentiment que c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sahel contre les
terroristes quel est votre constat la
menace et le risque d'une menace pour le
bas et que sa réponse également doit
être